good kids do me a favor if you got time
go to the link in the link in my bio in
the description and click on it man
watch Sun and lock down because they're
gonna close the judging tonight so
that's how the based on views is whether
or not you wind up getting thrown off
the show so if you can click on the link
below and watch a little latest edition
of Sun and lockdown
let's see already watch bro
thank you Midwest man I got you my guy
says Carson Thank You Wes this is love
you man I says thank you to Wesley you
got to answer Jason Mraz back I do how
awesome was that man I've got a little
cameo of sorts him and his buddy played
me and J I was tremendous I already
watched a dozen times thank you I will
for sure check it out says I think it
was goblin go we'll wait right here
hey from Puerto Rico says hey soos Kenny
says that was amazing
Wesley van says you're one of the best
screenwriters I am not stop it Wesley no
one's gonna take you seriously in this
life you go around saying like wooden
Smith's good at things they'll be like
then that means you can't be I hope
you're doing well says Jordan in
Australia from Chicago Washington give
it a thumbs up thank you Stewie land
Kevin your podcast got me through so
much Thank You Daniel
Smithers God Redman no he's not mm-hmm
Smith the smog hey keV don't worry if
wishes are wings we all fly we continue
to try says Daniel
that's beautiful Daniel let's see I was
just at the movies pop-up
we were streaming something you might
have watched and they gave me a big tray
of hater tots a big tray of hater tots
so I am going to bolt back into the
bedroom continue watching I may destroy
you which is excellent and on HBO and
eat some eat the [ __ ] out of some hater
tots ma'am what's your night gonna be
like kids
I hope there's I hope you're having as
good a time as I'm about to have by
myself
my wife's here too she might join me but
I don't need anybody to have a good time
when I got a tray full of hater tots
just LA
you can order movies right now man if
even if you live someplace else in the
United States and you're like I can't
get to Los Angeles don't worry about it
you can order movies right now go to
movies pop up calm and you can order it
anywhere in the u.s. anywhere in the
world ma'am Ralph Garman coming over
tonight
my buddy Ralph Garman would finally do
some Hollywood babble-on so there it is
when you're done watching this kids go
down to that link below and watch the
latest son walk down so I get them
clicks so I can stay on the show every
week I stay on the show they donate
money to the National Black Justice
Coalition so you know it's for a good
cause but it's also fun to deal with
stuff but I didn't expect to make it
past week two or three I'll be honest
with you so here we are thanks for
keeping me on there it is folks thank
you go watch this on a lockdown Gorder
some movies pop up and I'm
go talk to Ralph see you guys later